Peer Feedback is a tool many classes
use for peer to peer review.
The first time you're enrolled in
a class that uses Peer Feedback,
you'll receive an email invitation.
The link in that email will take
you to the account creation screen.
Create your account using the email
that was pre-populated in the form, and
then click Register.
Once you create your account you'll
see an invitation to join your class.
Then click accept.
The class will now appear
under your courses.
Once your class is underway, you'll
see a number of tasks on the right.
If your class lets you submit
assignments through Peer Feedback,
you'll see some seat
assignment tasks on the right.
>> Right now though, most classes that
use Peer Feedback have you submit your
assignment through either T-Square or
Udacity, and
then they copy the assignment
over to Peer Feedback.
So usually you won't submit
assignments directly to Peer Feedback.
>> If you have received some feedback,
from peers or
graders, you will see
the View Feedback buttons at the top.
Click one of those to see your feedback.
You'll see your scores along the rubric,
and you'll see some written feedback.
You can also give some meta
feedback in the field below,
which can only be seen
by the teaching team.
Back on the home screen,
if you have some feedback to give,
you'll see these Give Feedback buttons.
The data on the left is the deadline for
giving feedback.
Click Give Feedback to
review the assignment.
You'll see the assignment at the top,
and the rubric at the bottom.
Evaluate the assignment
according to the Rubric,
leave some written feedback,
and then click Submit.
And if you have more feedback to give,
you can click here and just keep going.
Finally, at any time,
you can review the feedback given and
received by clicking the course,
and then clicking the assignment.
You will see your assignment
submission on the left.
Feedback you have received
in the middle, and
feedback you have given on the right.
>> Some classes also use this tool for
grading.
They actually have the graders or TAs in
the system grading assignments the same
way the peers are giving feedback.
If you received a grade or
feedback from a TA through this system,
it will be marked with a TA icon
in the Feedback for You box